the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this is our last chance to this lecture
tonight is our last chance to pay
attention to this process I've been
calling the Fred OTT principle and I
forgive me for appearing a slightly
repetitious about this but it's to me
it's an essential aspect of our
appreciation of these early weeks to
recognize that films like the general or
modern times or the film we're going to
see next week the last laugh Murnau's
remarkable silent film from Germany to
recognize that these astonishing complex
narratives grew out of something so
primitive and grew out of something so
primitive in in such a relatively short
time it's part of what makes these early
films so interesting and this the
viewing you're going to see tonight is
your last opportunity to you know you
know in a concrete way experience
something of that process something of
that evolution for yourself because the
two Chaplin shorts that you're going to
see while they are as I indicated this
afternoon hardly from the earth not from
the earliest stages of Chaplin's work
they're three or four years I advanced
beyond that he's already mastered his
medium in certain ways and these shorts
are in themselves very coherent and
interesting works and I hope you'll you
know look at them for their own
intrinsic value but I also want you to
recognize as you think about those short
films remarkable as they are how much
richer how much more complex
how much more demanding and rewarding in
many ways modern times is and I think
the same thing could be said about all
of Chaplin's features there's an there's
an astonishing distance between even the
best shorts or between most of the best
shorts and the features the some of the
very best shorts have a kind of elegance
and purity as well as comic and a level
of comic inventiveness that makes them
in their own way almost the equal of the
features but of course they don't quite
even the best of them don't have quite
the reach or the resonance of a film
like modern times or the gold rush one
way we can perhaps clarify some of what
I've been saying and maybe also do a bit
more justice to poor Buster Keaton who I
think in many ways is
an equally remarkable artist if and in a
technical sense that even more
interesting director than Chaplin
himself is to begin with a comparison of
the two not so much because the
comparison will will illuminate
weaknesses in one or the other but it
will help to cut the contrast between
them I think will help to clarify what
are some of the essential qualities in
each of these in each of these directors
work and I hope in films and I hope that
you'll sort of think back to the keep
material you saw last week as I'm making
these comparisons right one way to think
about the differences between Chaplin
and Keaton and also to think about what
is essential about both of them is to
talk about the way they deal with
objects and the role that objects have
in their films in Keaton's case we might
say that the basic objects and of
interest are usually massive and
gigantic things whole whole houses
locomotives as in the general an ocean
liner as in the navigator and and Keaton
was interested in in intricate systems
and in the and in the intricacy with
which these systems operated and he
liked to he liked to pose his Buster
character against these massive systems
to see whether Buster could survive them
and to show us certain aspects of both
both of Buster's resourcefulness and
power to muddle through but also his
comic inadequacy in comic comic failings
as well and a number of the most
dramatic and famous bits from the
general could be said to crystallize
this principle think of that magnificent
joke it's more than a joke that that
cosmic joke that vision of experience
that that that that that existential
mockery that but also a affectionate
mockery of human nature that's embedded
in the Canon sequence at the very
beginning of Keaton's most important
film you remember how that works it
starts off in it's very funny at every
level but as as Keaton first fails to
fire the cannon then the second time
reloads the cannon with ten times as
much powder
then get stuck in front of the cannon
and it looks as if he's going to be shot
but everywhere every move along in that
in that in that sequence is full of
amusing comic business but think of how
as the as the joke builds as it as it as
it keeps topping itself something else
begins to happen what begins to emerge
as I suggested last time is almost a
kind of vision of life a vision of life
in which human agency matters you do
have to struggle and do what you can to
try to save yourself or accomplish your
ends but then when your ends are
accomplished even when things work out
almost exactly as you had planned
remember what happens the Canon does
fire it doesn't shoot at poor Buster who
runs away from it and hides at the
cowcatcher of the of the engine to avoid
it but why doesn't it good because at a
certain moment the train just happens to
go around a bend and geography and
physics collaborate with the Keaton
character in order to create a shot that
actually does almost hit the engine he's
pursuing and it certainly persuades the
people he's pursuing that they are being
chased by more than one man right so the
Esso the outcome and in fact them
remember how when the cannon fires and
we see that the outcome that results is
pretty much the outcome that the Buster
character intended there's a double
comedy there isn't there and it's a
metaphysical or an existential comedy
because what that joke is saying is of
course what the whole film also says and
what many other individual crescendo
jokes we might call them also say in the
film which is that we get through in
life by muddling through by working hard
by by by engaging in all kinds of
sometimes almost obsessive labor in
order to accomplish our ends but in the
end when we do accomplish our ends it's
not entirely because of us it's because
of continued it's because of accident
and when we don't accomplish our ends
it's also because of accident often as
well as because of our human frailty so
there really is a kind of complex
understanding of the world implicit in
the kinds of jokes that Keaton manages
to tell us and as if there's a sort of
understanding or interpretation of life
embedded in them in the best moments of
the general and these
this kind of vision of experience
wouldn't really be possible if Keaton
was as interested in individual
encounters with small objects as Chaplin
is because the distinction between
Caitlin Chaplin in terms of the way they
use objects is that Chaplin is in love
not with large gigantic structures and
but with tiny ones he wants to see how
Charlie manipulates his cane he wants to
watch Charlie interact with a hamburger
or with a or or with a or with a shoe
that he is pretending is a turkey dinner
in a in a in a fragment from a late film
of his that I'm going to show you and I
hope you know in a few moments so if
objects in Keaton are massive and and
systemic in a in a certain way the
objects that are most characteristic of
Chaplin's world are small and manageable
and the interactions between the
chaplain character and these objects are
often an occasion for the for the
exploration of character when the
Chaplin when the [ __ ] character
encounters a particular object one of
the things he is characteristically
tempted to do is to transform it's use
is to make it make it useful for some
other purpose as if the in the contest
between Charlie and the world
Charlie has some transcendent power to
allow his optimism to transform a
recalcitrant reality to make the reality
kind of Bend to him and it's especially
it becomes especially poignant as you'll
see in the passage from the Gold Rush
I'm going to show you in a little while
it becomes especially poignant when we
understand how minimal are the
constellations that Charlie finds when
he transforms this shoe into a turkey
dinner he's actually starving and
although it may psychologically help him
out we can see his resilience facing
hunger and making the shoe due for a
meal so what is expressed there is
something of the characters imaginative
nasaw something of his resilience and
optimism because when he encounters the
world his relation to it is one of a
magician or a transformer he's always
trying to impose his imagination on the
world and if you watch how Chaplin's if
you watch Chaplin's films this is true
of his shorts as well as his longer
films if you launch Chaplin's
interaction with objects closely you
we'll see a continual drama in which the
imaginative world of the [ __ ] is in
some sense in a kind of conflict or a
kind of collision or at least a kind of
angry conversation with the world in
which the objects of the world are well
though they may resist are are
constantly under the pressure of the
transformative power of Charlie's
optimism resilience and imagination so
with small objects in chaplain that
matter and they declare for character
rather than from that rather than for
some cosmic understanding of the world
we can get at another fundamental
difference and some of the strengths of
both Catholic eaten and the the
alternate kinds of strengths of both
Keaton and chaplain by talking about the
different protagonists or heroes that
are characteristic of their works in
chaplains case let's start with chaplain
we have often have heroes who have grand
visions or schemes or or hopes they tend
to be chivalric character so sometimes
the project they take on is rescue the
damsel protect protect the woman in in
in the first feature-length film or
nearly feature-length film that chaplain
made was a film called the kid and it
actually involves a child the kid of the
title is a young boy an urchin very much
like the real chaplain in in in in his
childhood in London and the [ __ ]
character who was himself starving
encounters the kid and has to protect
him so it's actually a story of a
maternal affair that there's a maternal
quality to Charlie and this he's but
much more like a mother than he's like a
father but anyway there's a kind it's a
kind of in in a certain sense a kind of
sentimental parenting fable in which we
see starving miserable down at the heels
Charlie defending a person who's even
more vulnerable and even more and even
weaker even less able to take care of
themselves
then then Charlie is and although it is
a deeply sentimental film in many ways
it also is a film that that provides
another occasion in which we can see the
[ __ ] characters imaginative nasaw
berating because when he's and as I
suggested in this afternoon one way you
can also see it operating as in chase
sequences because he does such a may he
make such amazing split-second decisions
about how to elude his
pursuers and they and often those
decisions reveal his intelligence and
his improv is Ettore quickness so almost
everything that happens in the Chaplin
film returns in some sense to our sense
of the tramps of the tramps character
and we feel that especially strongly I
think in in the kid because one of the
things that HAP I think the kid is 19 21
and one of the things that happens in
the kid is that we see Charlie exceeding
himself in imaginative resourcefulness
because he now has to protect a child
and what you feel is that his compassion
and his protective instincts net
mobilize a resourcefulness and an
intelligence that you can't help but
recognize and you can't help but see
so-and-so there in a certain sense
there's a grand scheme here protect the
child save a child's life or protect an
orphan or protect a protective a a young
damsel in distress from from bandits and
outlaws that sort of thing so it's it's
often the case that and then Chaplin
himself the character himself often has
grandiose visions of wealth or of
success right some of his films even
like as in modern times include dream
sequences or fantasy sequences in which
you can very very clever intelligent
sequences because you can tell that they
are taking place in a subjective realm
itself a kind of a thematic and and
technical advance in the making of
movies that Chaplin found ways to
introduce images that the audience would
recognize instantly as taking place not
in the real world but in the subjective
life of the characters as part of as
part of his achievement as a as a much
as amateur director
so the Chaplin the Chaplin hero was
often an ambitious character although he
often fails right he has large ambitions
he has chivalric tendencies he's hopeful
resilient in many ways grandiose and
sentimental and the chat and the Keaton
character couldn't be more opposite in
some ways he is sometimes been called
wrongly the great stone face but he's a
character who sort of muddles through
without any without any grand schemes
the Keaton character usually isn't
trying to do anything
the largest thing he ever tries to do is
impress a woman as he does in cops
mostly what he's just trying to do is
survive get through the day get around
the corner keep this ship from sinking
right keep keep this keep this
locomotive on the track right one might
even say that in the general which is
his most grandiose plan Menaul in all of
the Keaton's films but what the Buster
character does in the general is the
most ambitious and remarkable he's going
to recapture his trainees chasing the
he's chasing the Union Army as if he's
fighting the war on his own but it's
important to realize how we're supposed
to understand that in a deeply comic way
because the Keaton character is so
wedded to his engine that he's really
not thinking about any marshal victory
or a tour or war or or you know winning
the war what he wants to do is recover
his engine and even there so even there
there's a kind of smallness a kind of
lack of ambition a lack of grandiosity -
what the - what the Keaton character is
doing so he wants to just survive and do
a task again a very sharp contrast with
the treatment of women a third category
might be a way of seeing them in sharp
distinction to each other
Chaplin's treatment of women is deeply
sent to mental and chivalric they're
almost always with the partial exception
of modern times and I'll talk about that
briefly in a moment they're almost
always treated sentimentally and as
characters who need protection who are
weak and vulnerable as well as beautiful
and stand for some kind of purity they
are an inheritance or a vestige of the
Victorian ideal of women right they were
put on pedestals because they were too
pure for the world and they were also
too weak to open doors for themselves
they had to they had to have men do that
for them right so Chaplin's female
characters with the partial exception
demand dramatically partial exception of
the gamin in the film you're going to
see tonight tend to be of this sort
victorian stereotypes and his treatment
of them is deeply sentimental if you
think about the treatment of the heroine
in the general you'll see how
dramatically Keaton diverges from this
view remember he was not making fun of
women in that he's making fun of the
Victorian stereotype of women that
appears in so many movies
right so when the Keaton character picks
up that woman when she's hiding in the
potato sack and throws are over his
shoulders and throws her onto the pile
as if she's another sack of potatoes who
were later in the film when they when
the cheatin heroine begins to do such
stupid things that you begin to realize
that she is one of the great airheads in
the history of movies right remember
some of the tricks she pulls like she
said she ties a willow tree across the
tracks he ties a rope across the tracks
to stop the next train from come from
catching up with them or she sweeps out
remember this business where she sweeps
out in the cut in the in the in the in
the kept cabin of the engine while poor
Buster is struggling to keep the engine
going she doesn't like a little bit of
soot on the floor she is what what
Keaton makes fun of this figure but he's
not making fun of women he's not making
fun of actual feet living females he's
making fun of the stereotype of women
that appears in especially it not only
in the movies but also appears in sort
of the popular conception of what of
what women are in any case we can see
how deeply mocking and unsentimental
Keaton's treatment of women is one final
state perspective contrast that I think
is helpful and interesting might be the
contrast in that we might that we might
generate if we tried to describe the
visual style of each director Chaplin
favors close shots and emphasizes
character he aims for a totally
realistic style in which you're
oblivious to the cameras presence you're
not supposed to think about the camera
he wants to create a camera that is as
transparent as possible you're supposed
to just focus on the action as if
Chaplin's idea is that his camera is a
window on reality and he wants he
doesn't want the look he doesn't want
the window or the window pane to be part
of your understanding of what you're
watching he just wants to there's
something there's something social and
and character oriented in Chaplin's
visual style and especially in his
preference for close-ups which reveal
the psychology of character right the
contrast with with Keaton is very
dramatic hedonism a more interesting
director in a technical sense he's much
more he'll mix his shots much more often
he'll use
but he also loves long shots and middle
shots depending on the effect he's
looking for if you think about what a
master he is of the long shot think of
the moment for example in the general
where the camera backs up far enough so
that we can see Buster working furiously
on the on the the car that carries the
wood the wood carrier on his on his
train working furiously with his head
down while we see the train move across
the battle line so that he ends up in
enemy territory and he doesn't even know
it right so there's a kind of cosmic
joke B and again it's a joke that's only
possible in the movies I mean it's a
joke that partly depends upon the
cameras position its power to photograph
motion and the fact that it can
encompass much larger scenery but a much
larger meson sin then is ever possible
in the live theatre right so in many
ways so it's a it's a it's a technically
interesting achievement but it's also a
morally interesting achievement because
what does it dramatize the usual trick
the usual thing we know about the Buster
character he's mostly oblivious to the
dangers around him and he often often
the comedy in Keaton comes from the fact
that he's oblivious to his narrow
escapes as we as we've said before so he
uses so-so Keaton u Keaton uses mixed
shots he's much more interested in
creating an aura of authenticity in his
in his filming the general especially
alludes to documentary photography made
during the Civil War and some of the
images are actually recreations of
Mathew Brady photographs very famous
Mathew Brady photographs it was very
important for Keaton to create these
realistic effects these realistic the
sense of realism because so many of his
most magnificent jokes depend on your
recognition that it's actually happening
that he's not using processed shots that
he's doing that he's think of for
example of the unbelievable engineering
feat that was involved in the final
crash of the Train when the bridge burns
at the end of the general remember he
couldn't there's no there's no digital
animation then when when Keaton did that
if he didn't get it on the camera the
first time that was it right it and in
fact it's incredibly beautifully done it
captain's perfectly this is something
almost graceful about that about that
catastrophic sequence it's so well done
in fact it even holds up today in an era
when we are so used to special effects
of a much more dramatic and astonishing
kind there are no special effects in
that in that sequence it depended on a
mastery of knowing where to put the
camera a kind of Engineers mastery of
various individuals and machines that
were in motion at the same time
perfect timing so that the bridge had to
actually burn down at just the right
moment for the train to come over there
was no margin for error there again and
again Keaton's comedy shows us this
level of technical as well as
intellectual or thematic mastery because
of course that moment when the train
crashes into the canyon isn't just a
magnificent visual moment and a
magnificently comic courting of the
expectations of the generals who are run
in the brain but it but but the scene is
that moment is also completely
consistent with the mock heroic interest
the mock heroic themes of the movie of
the movie l as a whole and what I'd like
to do now is concretize and and and
embody the arguments I've been making
very briefly and inadequately
by having you look at three scenes one
from Keaton
two from Chaplin that can help ground
what I've been saying in particular
images and particular moments the first
scene is a scene that I wanted to show
you last week and didn't have time I
think of it in a certain sense as an as
a particularly clear embodiment of what
we might call the Keaton vision and it's
a it's a it's a sequence that violates
one of Keaton's deepest principles at
the very end and I'm a little sorry it
does then the sequence is harmed by that
there is a special effect in it and it's
too bad that there is more but it's one
of the very rare such moments in Keeton
Keeton tried never to do that and as I
mentioned to you sometimes very
dangerous things happen to Keaton and
they happen in reality he was often
begged at they went when he became a
director of features to not do his own
stunts but he always refused and he
always did his own stunts he broke his
neck when he was making the general and
he any any continued filming with with a
broken neck for part of the time well he
he didn't quite realize how seriously he
was injured when
when that happened if you think back to
the general you might actually be able
to figure out it happens in relatively
early in the film when he when he hurt
himself when he's on the handcar when
he's chasing on the hand carny falls off
the hand car and he actually did real
harm to himself in that in that sequence
okay so this in this first sequence it
comes from cops and in many ways I think
it embodies that kind of a version of
the trajectory or crescendo joke I was
talking about earlier it's a small
version of the cannon joke that you see
in or jokes plural because there's
another joke with the cannon in the
second half of the film that that I've
talked about earlier let's show it great
and of course this is the moment where
Keaton is in flight from the police the
cops are chasing me runs up this
teeter-totter right here he gets he runs
up a ladder and turns out to be a like a
like a seesaw and there we see the
Buster character trying to elude cops
who come up on either side of the
teeter-totter right now now what does
that you see his acrobatic qualities but
part of it of course is that part of
what makes it good is that we know he's
improvising here he's in trouble people
on both ends now are after him how can
he escape this right teeter totter up
and down seems as if there's no escape
it's almost as if every cop in the city
is now after poor Buster right massive
forces arrayed against the the lone hero
a key to his company and yet and of
course that's the process shot but it is
a very witty way to end right I mean
what does it depend on among other
things and engineers understanding of
the laws of motion right and it depends
it did Minea Keaton's jokes depend on a
kind of collaboration with with gravity
I mean he had to yeah and call attention
to that so he said so his it seems as if
there's no escape and he does not escape
because of anything that he himself has
really done it's contingent it's
accidental but he does escape right it's
as if it's as if the universe sometimes
not always conspires to help us if we
try hard sometimes it'll help us
sometimes it won't
we're mostly foolish characters muddling
through the
jokes say that again and again it's a
vision of life now and I want to turn to
what to contrast this kind of joking and
this kind of style again think of how
the camera had to for that effective
work the camera had to be pretty far
back it had to do it dependent it
depended on your seeing the seesaw going
up and down it depended on your seeing
the cops on either side of the ladder
right so so it's in that sense it's a
characteristic Keaton moment a
characteristic eating passage well I
want to show you two passages from
feature films of Chaplin's that I think
of this characteristic moments of
Chaplin and you'll see how they fit into
what I've already said first a scene
from the gold rush and let me set it up
for you the goal that one of the
delightful and important things about
the tramps character as I mentioned this
afternoon is after a while but the
Chaplin made a total of 81 films the
vast majority of them were silent films
after after the first couple of films
that he made the [ __ ] character began
to elaborate itself and and proceeded by
a principle of accretion that's very
important for us to be aware of because
think of what this means if the audience
for modern times had seen 50 Chaplin
shorts or most of Chaplin's movies and
if this would have been true the in 1936
the vast majority of the movie audience
would have lived through the silent era
would and certainly would have known a
great many Chaplin films so that when
they came to see modern times they had
in their memory banks all these other
stories about the [ __ ] and in fact this
they didn't have to wait for modern
times for this effect to occur right as
the [ __ ] began to generate a kind of
reputation and more and more people came
to watch him what began to happen was
the each subsequent adventure of the
[ __ ] got richer not because of anything
inherent in the new adventure
but because the previous adventures lay
behind it and were part of the tramps
ongoing identity so as the audience
became more familiar with the [ __ ] and
as Chaplin's gifts for for dramatizing
character and for making movies enlarged
so did the resonance of the [ __ ] as a
figure and I should have said this this
afternoon because it's the deepest
explanation for why the
became a mythic figure why the trend
became such a such a such a memorable
and powerful icon and and in this in
this sequence you're going to see one of
the classic instances of the tramps
resilient imaginative 'no sin the face
of difficulty and danger in the my in
the gold riders in the gold rush the
identity that charlie takes on by the
time he comes to make his feature films
there are dozens and dozens thirty forty
short films behind in the past so that
and all of those identities all of those
adventures feed into and inform the more
recent ones when the audience then comes
to watch modern times it has that and
and the gold rush it has that history
behind it in this particular scene what
in its particular film charlie takes on
the identity of a 49er who's gone to not
a not a football player but a miner
who's gone to Alaska for the Alaska Gold
Rush right we've seen him as a waiter
we've seen him as a ship builder we've
seen him as a pawn brokers assistant
we've seen him we've seen him in in in
in a whole range of other jobs almost
and until modern times each film even
the even the feature-length films only
show Charlie in one occupation it's only
in modern times where we see him in
multiple occupations is one of the
things that marks modern times greater
complexity from the early from the
earlier film well in this film now but
so what's happened he goes to Alaska he
finds himself stuck in a cabin after a
terrible Avalanche and snowstorm he's
stuck in the cabin without food with a
massive gigantic fellow one of his
favorite antagonists max Wain there's
Namath and chaplin certainly chose him
because he was so humongously large that
when he Justin when he was juxtaposed
against Charlie he looked even even more
menacing well in the sequence you're
about to see Charlie is an is is
confined in a cabin in a horrible
snowstorm starving with this gigantic
fellow who's beginning to look at
Charlie as if he might be a tasty morsel
and it's Thanksgiving it's Thanksgiving
they're about to have Thanksgiving
dinner what are they going to do watch
Charlie's imaginative response ok great
even before this we've seen the max
Wayne character look at Charlie with a
kind of hungry eye and you'll see him do
it again here watch how Charlie
interacts with particular objects with
small objects he's what he's done is
he's cooked a boot
one of their shoes the shoelaces become
spaghetti
did you see the subtlety of that moment
where Charlie looked frightened what
watch the range of emotions that he's
able to express in his face now you see
how he uses close-ups how it's a drama
of character see no he lacks Charlie's
imaginative nough so he doesn't survive
as well it's almost like mind over
matter and that it's that quality in
each app in the chaplain character I
think more than any other that explains
why people loved him
you see if you act like you're eating
good food you almost are all right
that's enough Greg little bit you get
the idea it's a remarkable film and you
get a night
now the next scene the next sequence I
want to show you was in some sense even
more powerful maybe let it's less comic
it's it's one of this sort of although
there are comic elements in it it's it's
it's chaplain that his most dramatic and
it's this it's the final sequence of the
film city lights the film that precedes
modern times by far there are five year
separate them but it's the it's the last
film he made before modern times and
it's a it's essentially an urban drama
in which the tram character finds
himself protecting a vulnerable woman
and the woman he's protecting is is a
blind flower girl she's blind and so
she's even even more vulnerable and and
deserving of protection than that then a
sighted flower girl who would be and so
Charlie so Charlie sort of takes her
under his wing and she because she's
blind she doesn't realize there's a kind
of trick in the beginning a visual trick
that makes the blind flower girl believe
that Charlie is a wealthy man and
Charlie allows her to believe this he
pleased the [ __ ] but he allows her to
believe that he's wealthy and he visits
whether he takes getting it and he she
has an older she has an agent mother or
something like the character you see in
the immigrant who dies in the course of
the film and and Charlie Charlie
the second subplot in the film has
Charlie befriending a very wealthy man
who's incredibly nice to him when he's
drunk and kicks him out of his life when
he's sober and his his irrationality is
part of Chaplin's critique of capitalism
I think because he's a he's a rich man
right but when he's drunk he loves
Charlie and he gives Charlie money and
so forth but Charlie uses this to get a
fortune and he sent he sees an article a
newspaper about about a Swiss doctor who
can fix blindness and he sends the
flower girl to Switzerland to or some
place to have her and the files and she
has the operation she has she has her
sight regained and at the very end of
them and the
tram character has had his we had his
usual misadventures and he's just
getting out of prison at the very end of
the film
so the encounter he's going to have with
the now site and flower girl which is
the very climax of city lights this
encounter that is going to have with her
is an encounter in which he and the
audience know perfectly well who all the
characters are but she has never set
eyes on Charlie before and she has the
idea that the man that that her her
benefactor the man who who sent her for
the operation and restored her sight is
a wealthy and handsome fellow here is
the ending of city lights
so for the audience this moment has
tremendous poignant because the audience
is aware of things that the female
character is not aware of that there's
her benefactor this shabby little [ __ ]
so her condescension to him in this
sequence has tremendous poignant for the
audience and look at short look at the
close-up on Charlie here Charlie sees
who it is Charlie knows who it is
the only thing that's wrong with this
ending is the titles are unnecessary the
faces are so eloquent they're on
unnecessary the words don't need aren't
needed in fact the words even simplify
can you see how Charlie's expression
involves Pride and as well as affection
and a kind of and a kind of love he's
incredibly excited and happy to see her
and to see her sighted
see the power of a close-up she suddenly
realizes who it is from touch
the least necessary into title in the
history of movies is about to appear but
look at the close-ups here look at the
art of these close-ups another
unnecessary line
there are people who have said that that
last close-up is the most eloquent
close-up in the history of movies it
might be true because the complexity of
emotion that's playing across Charlie's
face there it's hard for people who
haven't seen the whole film to fully
grasp it although I tried to set it up
it's partly that he knows there can
never be anything between them it's
partly that he's full of joy over the
fact that he's been able to help her but
there's also a sense of their inevitable
separation of the differences between
them and that's part of what's reflected
in Charlie in that close-up at the end
and another thing I would call your
attention to a part of Chaplin subtlety
is look how he doesn't hold it too long
really mom a truly sentimental director
would have held his final C his final
shot at Charlie's face twice as long
three times as long but do you notice
how it wasn't there for very long you
his hand was over here he's ending and
then the screen goes blank
he doesn't milk the moment even though
it's an immensely complicated moment but
the most important thing to say about
this scene is that it's a scene that's
played out by the drama of the face
it shows how Chaplin had reached a point
by the time he reached his maturity in
the in the 1920s and reached a point
where he could create films in which
close-ups on expressive actors faces and
especially close ups on the tramps face
could could reveal worlds of meaning the
range of contradictory feelings and
meanings that run across the theatre of
Charlie's face in these final sequences
of city lights are proof of the
eloquence of the silent film and are
particularly distinctive signature
instance of Chaplin's of Chaplin's art
well in the time I have remaining what
I'd like to do is talk very quickly
about modern times itself the great
masterpiece that you're going to be
seeing in a few minutes as a way of sort
of setting up some of the things for you
to watch for I can be very it but I it
seemed I feel badly that I couldn't do
this fully enough with the general which
is an equally complex film and I only
have a few minutes here so I can hardly
do full justice to the astonishing
richness and complexity of modern times
but I want to call your attention to
certain features in it and count on your
being as attentive and as generous in
your viewing as you possibly can I'm
sure you'll pick up other things as well
the context of the film I've already
mentioned this I don't have to spend a
lot of time on it but it's very
interesting and significant that the
film was made in 1936 released in 1936
something like seven or eight years into
the sound era there hadn't been any
silent films made now I'm not saying
that modern times is actually a truly
silent film it's not it has a soundtrack
and the soundtrack is complex and rich
and I'll say a least a word about it
before I'm before I'm finished here but
it but in every fundamental respect
modern times wants its viewers to think
of it as it as a silent film it invokes
the tradition of silent film and
especially the tradition of Chaplin
films to which it systematically alludes
in virtually every frame so the the the
context for the film is first that it is
that it is in a certain way a kind of
silent film there is no synchronous
dialogue in it so it remains in some
sense there is there is there are sound
effects but and of course there's music
a soundtrack that Chaplin arranged very
complex Lee and it's a very rich
soundtrack but there but there's no
synchronous dialogue until the very end
at the very end there is synchronous
dialogue and it's Charlie who speaks it
in fact the film was advertised as
follows in many newspapers who says the
[ __ ] speaks well watch for what happens
when the [ __ ] speaks you know it's a
it's it's one of the films great and
serious jokes he does speak at the end
and it's the only moment you do hear
dialogue elsewhere in the film I'm
getting ahead of myself this is what I
wanted to say about sound but you don't
see people you don't see you don't see
synchronous dialogue you don't see
people moving their lips and words
coming out of it you see people on a
screen talking or you hear people on a
radio talking but you don't see someone
on screen actually moving his lips and
words sound coming out until the very
end when Charlie does his song he sings
a song he plays a waiter near the end of
the film and he sings a song and he
tells a story with a song they watch for
what happens so the tram does talk but
it's a wonderful cosmic comic joke
another aspect of the context of modern
times as it takes place during the
Depression right but the subject matter
of modern times was tipped with
Chaplin's typical subject matter
it was the it was about the depression
it was about hunger about misery about
someone who can't find a job about two
homeless people about about the about
the conflict between capital and labor
about the irrationality of both sides
it was literally about the turmoil and
trouble that was going on during the
Great Depression many people predicted
not only that the film would fail
because it was really essentially a
silent film in an era when no one was
interested in silent film anymore but
also that would fail because it was
rubbing the audience's noses in the very
experiences they were trying to escape
when they came to the movies The
Escapist theory of why people attend
films of course both predictions were
mistaken the modern times was a
significant commercial success partly
because Chaplin was very clever in the
way he did his exhibition of the film he
released it first not in mass release
but to elite theaters which charged
quite a great deal of money and then
slowly allowed the film to reach larger
and larger theaters he anticipated
certain modern marketing methods with
the release of modern town and of course
by the by 1936 Charlie Chaplin was an
internationally famous figure of such
stature he was about the only figure
maybe apart from DW Griffith about whom
people had begun to write essays calling
him an artist so he what the Chaplin
Chaplin occupied a unique place and that
was part of also part of why what modern
times was waited for so so fully so the
cont the context of modern times is
important and there's something brave
and surprising about the fact that it
was about the miseries of the depression
during the Depression that it was
essentially a silent film in the middle
of the sound era both very bold
decisions by Chaplin's part both
characteristic of his of his
ambitiousness as a as an artist I like
Keaton's the general we could certainly
call this film also a culminating text a
summarizing text and when it was in
several senses
it's a culminating text in terms of
Chaplin's work and I've already talked
about that every single person coming to
see modern times who had any experience
with the movies before would recognize
in modern times situations and even
physical spaces that had occurred in
earlier Chaplin films so there was
almost a sense in which modern times was
a reprise of the whole career of the
[ __ ] and I mentioned that modern time
shows us the [ __ ] for the first time in
multiple jobs having multiple sources of
and and in fact he multiple
misadventures he goes to jail more than
once in the film we find him we find him
in a factory more than once in the film
and so forth so there's a there's a
sense in which the various separate
episodes of modern times taken together
dramatize in small the whole of the
tramps career and and there are many
specific bits of business and scenes in
modern times that are literal
repetitions or echoes or reprises of
earlier Chaplin's films which would have
caused a kind of recognition of
recognition in in the audience of a
happy kind of recognition many examples
of that there are many earlier films
which deal with rester you'll see some
of them from the shorts that you've
looked at certain echoes I won't talk
about any of them beyond mentioning that
there's a remarkable sequence in the
film if we have time I'll show it to you
probably we probably won't have time in
which we see Charlie on skates and that
scene alludes to a whole short that
Chaplin had made in which he plays a
waiter who has to serve people on skates
and you'll see that he has to do that
again at the end of the film he sort of
reprises that role and then there's an
earlier moment in the film where we see
Chaplin on skates as well but the main
point is that that that virtually every
moment in modern times has some
counterpart in an earlier Chaplin short
short so there would have been a sense
of the audience coming back to Charlie
Reid returning to the world that Charlie
stood for when they came to watch when
they came to watch modern times but it's
a culminating text and so it's a
culmination of Chaplin's career but it's
also in a deep sense like the general a
culmination of silent film and it would
have had that nostalgic effect it would
have had that nostalgic effect on the
original audience the original audience
would have record with most of the
original audience would have would have
recognized the film as as a as an
embodiment of a phase of movie going
that had gone that had passed and we
should watch it in that in that in that
way as as well I want to say a word
about the gamin that's that
that's the character of the female
character in the film because she
represents an advance over any previous
Chaplin movie as I suggested earlier
most Chaplin most Chaplin films in most
Chaplin's films the women are are
relatively stereotyped and don't play
very active roles this is the first film
in which there's a woman who seems to be
in some sense the tramps equal in many
ways more than is equal she has more
energy she's a bit younger you might
watch for the ambiguity in their
relations is it a sexual relationship a
romantic relate
Charlie's a lot older than the gamin in
real life he was having an affair with
her we may I might mention to you
Atman he was in fact he was famous for
for having relations with young women
wasn't one of the for me especially his
young actresses and there was a there
were scandals connected to Chaplin's
name partly because of this and Paulette
Goddard the actress who plays the gamin
in this film entered on a career of
greats of great fate a great great Fame
in the movies partly because of this
role and you can see how expressive and
remarkable her face is this is the first
female character who has energy will who
has a kind of aggressive capacity to be
resilient and care for herself and that
represents a tremendous advance in
Chaplin's work she's the first sort of
semi independent female in Chaplin's
work and you can see in a certain way
she's a kind of partner for Chaplin when
this film ends with Charlie and the
gamin walking down the road toward an
unknown future the only difference
between that ending and the ending we
normally see in a Chaplin short is the
Chaplin is usually alone when he when he
walks down the road toward the mountains
in the distance and in this film he has
a partner so there's a there's a slight
suggestion of if not exactly hopefulness
at least of resilience or the capacity
to survive you have some you have
someone to help you and you might watch
the way the Paulette Goddard character
is treated in the film because she
actually represents something new in
Chaplin's work on a real a real advance
in his understanding of how to deal with
female cat with female characters a new
kind of respect for women show up in
this in in this in this film I've
mentioned the soundtrack before and but
I want to quickly call your attention to
two features of it one
is that Chaplin arranged the the
soundtrack very carefully and what
you'll notice if you pay attention is
that the soundtrack has what we might
call a quality of in which in which
particular themes are recur when certain
characters appear on screen and you
begin to associate certain melodies and
with certain characters and you should
watch the way this unfolds I mean that
the the the the song of the melody
that's played behind the chaplain
character was actually a popular song of
the day and titled although the words
are never sung in the film hallelujah
I'm a [ __ ]
and it was a song about being free and
not not having to worry about working
and riding the rails and so forth hooray
I don't have a job hooray I'm I'm I'm
I'm free in those ways but each of the
character each of the major characters
in the film has a musical theme
associated with him or her and you
should watch the way they sort of meld
in and blend blend together its Chaplin
took the sound in the film very
seriously and I've mentioned the talking
theme watch how watch the mocking way in
which talk itself spoke speech is dealt
with in the soundtrack I you might want
to talk about this in your recitations
but ask yourself what's going on there
why would Chaplin in in the end
denigrates talk I think the answer is
obvious the [ __ ] is a silent character
it's as if it's as if this is the
revenge of silent film on talkies right
it's as if the film is saying talk is
crap talk is silly
talk is ridiculous who needs talk watch
how the film repeatedly makes fun of
talking or shows talking in it's as as
inadequate or or or or or or unnecessary
as if the as if the filming and also the
way the film associate talk is with
something else that the film is very
hostile to which is mechanized
industrialization right the film is a
critique of the excesses of capitalism
and the excesses especially the tedium
of factory work and it's and and talk
and talking films are associated with
that with that with what the film
identifies as evil or dangerous as
you'll see but there's also a moment in
the film that I won't show it to you but
it's a but but but I'll mention it
ask you to watch for it where we can see
another way it's only one of the ways in
which chaplin manipulates sound so
greatly is it an interesting moment
cause it's easy to miss easy not to
register what's happening there there's
a moment in the center of the film where
Charlie and the gamin escaped their
difficulties briefly Charlie gets a job
as a night watchman in a department
store and the department store is like
capitalist heaven they've been living on
hand-to-mouth nearly starving charlie
fine and they find themselves in the
department store there's food there's
their beds there are beautiful warm
clothes there are toys there are even
rollerskates and there's a moment when
Charlie and the gamin exploring the
store having this exciting experience
with all these goods which they're
deprived of it's not an accident that
that scene is at the very center of the
film almost all the scenes on either
side of the department store scene rhyme
with each other in certain ways as an
aspect of the structure of the film and
I'll come to that in a second I'll
conclude with that point but the
department store scene is the only one
that doesn't have any counterpart it's
right at the very center of the film and
what one can feel is the way in which
that dramatizes the sense the the
injustice the sense of haves and
have-nots that is at the center of the
film's meaning that the film is always
in some sense interested in that in that
topic so there's a moment when the gamin
and Charlie find themselves in this
store Charlie in his exuberance and high
spirit straps on rollerskates and begins
skating around and if you listen to the
soundtrack you'll see the soundtrack is
very beautiful and gentle and you know
it's very calming and exciting and and
as charlie is skating the camera shows
that in fact he's skating in a very
dangerous area the store is partly under
construction and as he one point while
he's skating he puts a blindfold on and
he's still skating very calmly and
beautifully and gracefully and the
soundtrack under it is very graceful and
appropriate to his feelings but what to
feel what the camera shows what you see
is him coming near the end as you of an
abyss actually it's a platform he might
fall three stories down into the lower
story and he's not aware of it because
he's blindfolded and the sand the sand
but when you if you look and then of
course there's a certain moment he takes
the blindfold off and he sees that he's
about to fall and he gets nervous and he
he suddenly is no longer so graceful
it's a kind of comic it's kind of minor
joke but
really interesting about them moment is
to think about what Chaplin is doing
with the soundtrack because when you
reflect on it what you realize is that
what Chaplin has done with that
soundtrack is have it reflect not the
external reality that we're all watching
but the inner feelings that Charlie is
feeling but he's done is he's discovered
away it's a simple point but it's a
brilliant discovery he's discovered a
way to use the soundtrack to express a
subjective state right this is so that
and what he's also discovered of course
is that although other people had
discovered this principle too but
Chaplin's using it with great
intelligence he's discovered that the
soundtrack and the visual track don't
have to absolutely coincide that they
can report different emotions or or
cause different kinds of reactions and
that what you get when you have this
disjunction is something much more
complex we see Charlie as skating in
danger but his obliviousness to the
danger is partly registered by the music
which tells us not about what's
happening outwardly but what's happening
inside Charlie and there are other
moments like this in the film not
necessarily with the soundtrack but in
other ways in which the subjective
states of the characters are explored
pay attention to those because they're
very remarkable and interesting moments
in which Chaplin is expanding the
repertoire of a film the structure of
the film is especially interesting and
and I won't say more about it than to
say if you watch closely what you will
see is the structure is a profound
structure of repetition as in the
general the film's first half is
revisited in the film second half it's
as if the film is based on a series of
rhyming scenes in the first half of the
film there's a fantasy sequence in which
we see Charlie and the gamin in inside a
kind of cabined environment inside a
kind of domestics it's actually a
fantasy scene in which Charlie imagines
a suburban heaven for him and the gamin
in the second half of the film there's
an actual cabin in the mud flats that
they live in and those two scenes are
sort of in conversation with each other
there are two extended sequences in
factories and involving the
malfunctioning of machinery and so why
you'll notice if you pay close attention
to the film is that is that this
principle of rhyming scenes creates a
situation in which
the sake in the second half of the film
you partly feel that you're revisiting
scenes and experiences that you've had
before and one of the reasons that this
is a useful and an important idea is
that if you think about Charlie's life
and you think about the previous history
of Chaplin's career as a director and as
an actor what you realize is that in a
deep sense what modern times is doing is
replicating the history of Charlie's
career because Charlie has held a series
of jobs Charlie has Charlie has been in
15 or 20 or 40 or a hundred different
environments
and in virtually every case in every
case the ending has been the same he has
been released into a new into an
ambiguous kind of homelessness and
freedom at the end of the film here's
something Footloose
homeless and unfinished about Charlie's
life and after a while you come to
realize you this would have been true in
the inn by 1920 if you had paid
attention to the 30 or so other Chaplin
shorts that already existed the fact is
that it's an endless process so another
thing that the structure of modern times
manages to dramatize maybe more deeply
and powerfully than any prior Chaplin
film has have been able to do exactly
because of this mirror structure is that
this principle of repetition never ends
that Charlie is on a kind of treadmill
and of course Charlie revisits the
scenes and repeats actions that we'd
seen earlier in the film because his
life is a series of repetitions because
the film's vision of social life for a
character like Charlie is one that's so
mordant what he's suggesting is things
are hard things are tough this man's
homelessness this man's hunger will
never abate he's going to have a
struggle for his whole life but we don't
despair because the chaplain character
himself doesn't despair and and so
paying attention to the way the
structure and bodies the meaning the
point I'm making now and I'll come back
to this later in the course the point
I'm making now is a way of talking about
what could be called the film's
commitment to the principle of organic
form when when the structure of the text
is organic what that what is meant by
that is that the structure itself
embodies the meaning that the structure
that the way the text is organized
carries the
themes of the text and if you think
about the structure of modern times
you'll see that it's a marvelously
distilled instance a marvelously clear
instance of the principle of organic
form what happens to Charlie serially is
more meaningful in a way than what
happens to him in a single episode and
the fact that this that we have this
sense that things are repeating that
Charlie's on a treadmill that he lives a
cyclical life that he'll always have
moments of hope and hopelessness that
he'll have momentary times when he's
free of when he's when he finds a place
to live or find sufficient food but then
it will always be temporary that his
life is that his life is always on the
road that his life is always in process
that's and that at the same time he
never lets himself completely despair
he's oh there's always a moment where
his resilience reasserts himself a
reassert reasserts itself
well those elements are embedded in some
sense in this very structure the very
organization of the film and I urge you
to watch it what's been embedded or
implied in a good deal of what I've been
saying tonight tonight has to do with
what broadly also has to do broadly with
what might be called Charlie Chaplin's
as the director Chaplin's complexity
almost every moment in Chaplin and
certainly almost every moment in modern
times has the kind of multiplicity or
density or texture that I've been
describing to you as the mark of
seriousness of a serious film the mark
of what I want to call a work of art and
if you pay attention one of the things
you'll find is that even then even the
moments that seem on the surface to be
the simplest ones are not or even the
implications in the film that seem the
simplest are not just one example the
film's critique of capitalism of a
certain kind of excessive form of
industrial capitalism is obvious and
very deep its it the film is deeply
hostile to the to the dehumanization
that factory that work on the assembly
line generates for people and Chaplin
works wonderfully comic variations on
this idea and yet if you think of the
film in a simple way when you think in
the film in a simple way as a as a kind
of Marxist or left-wing the screen
you're really mistaken and some people
did in fact in Chaplin Chaplin was
hounded out of the out of the United
States later in his career in part
because he was associated with
we're thought to be left-wing causes eye
but Chaplin socialism was of a
particularly sentimental variety and he
was certainly no systematic communist
but the most important thing about
Chaplin is his complexity because if you
look closely at the film one of the
things you'll find that it isn't just
capital that's criticized it's also
labor there's a wonderful moment in the
film when Charlie finally after after
times of difficulty reads in the
newspaper that the factory is hiring
again and he's very excited and he
leaves the gamin they've been living in
their little sort of idyllic cabin in
the mud flats in the second half of the
family runs out to the factory he gets
hired and just as he's about to start
his work the workers go on strike
right and his life is destroyed again
and in fact the the truth of the matter
is that Chaplin is an equal-opportunity
insult er he thinks that labor is just
as stupid organized labor is just as
foolish just as misguided as capital
something of his of the complexity of
his social vision is reflected there and
something of the complexity of his moral
and psychological vision is reflected in
the way the [ __ ] interacts with the
gamin and in the way in which both the
[ __ ] and the gamin together at
different moments in the film try to
buck each other up so we see that there
are moments in which each character
falls into a kind of despair in the face
of the difficulties that that they
encounter and in which they are helped
by their by their partner so there's a
kind there's a kind of complexity or or
or or maturity in Chaplin's way of
understanding even the social
difficulties the social evils the social
problems that he recurringly dramatizes
in his film for those of you who have
never seen a Chaplin film before and
especially those of you who have never
seen modern times let me conclude by
saying I'm a little bit jealous of the
opportunity you have to see this film
for the first time it's one of the very
few silent films I think I think the
general is also one that actually stands
on its own that's worth watching even
without any arguments about its
artificial heart a factual value I wish
you the joy of this remarkable film
you